This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这是有电梯可坐时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《百分之二》。在这个光怪陆离的现代世界里，我将为你剖析心理韧性、健身以及培养抗逆力的秘诀。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《百分之二》。认准数字“2”percent。欢迎收听《回顾往昔》（Look Back at It）播客。1979年，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。1984年对我意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾往昔》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难求知》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全却又坦诚的对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一身铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就非得这么做。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难求知》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个恶作剧。艾伦女士，你对这个特定的测试造假了两次，对吗？我造假了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困于爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困于爱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客里，我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, whatever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we dive into the psychology of our 20s. I have a super fascinating topic for you all today. One that has been on my mind quite a lot recently and on my list for some time as well, but I've never really gotten around to talking about it until now. Today is the day we are going to be talking about that kind of sickening feeling of retroactive jealousy, feeling jealous over your partner's past, the people they used to date, the sex they had before you, the love they felt with other people, feeling like their past has some impact.
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到本播客。无论你是新听友、老听友，还是身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，让我们一起深入探讨二十岁的心理学。今天我有一个超级吸引人的话题要带给大家。这个话题最近一直在我的脑海里盘旋，也在我的清单上待了一段时间，但我直到现在才真正腾出时间来聊聊它。今天就是我们要聊聊那种让人觉得恶心的“回溯性嫉妒”感的时候了，因为伴侣的过去而感到嫉妒，嫉妒他们以前约会过的人、在你之前发生过的性关系、他们对其他人感受到的爱，觉得他们的过去对……
some influence on your current or your future together. This kind of jealousy feels like a reaction that neither of you can control because it's about something that your person, your partner, can't undo. You also can't undo it. The past is the past. And before they met you, it's this weird reality where how could they have predicted that they would end up in this relationship and not the one that they had before? I think that retroactive jealousy is particularly fascinating because normally jealousy occurs in response
对你们现在或未来的生活有某种影响。这种嫉妒感觉就像是一种你们谁也无法控制的反应，因为它是关于你深爱的那个人、你的伴侣无法抹去的事情。你也无法抹去它。过去就是过去。在他们遇见你之前，这是一个奇怪的现实：他们怎么能预测到自己最终会进入这段感情，而不是之前的感情呢？我认为回溯性嫉妒特别迷人，因为通常嫉妒是对……
to present day actions or feeling threatened by a current relationship, current words, current behaviours, but with retroactive jealousy, the actions that you are concerned about normally occurred before they even knew you existed. So it's really confusing and our rational brain normally understands how logical it is to hold our partners past over them, but there is this emotional and I would say vulnerable, often insecure part about ourselves that can't help it. It's a compulsion. It's this unconscious feeling and fear that maybe what they had before is better than what
当下的行为作出反应，或者因当前的恋爱关系、当前的话语、当前的行为而感到受到威胁，但对于回溯性嫉妒，你所担忧的行为通常发生在你甚至不知道他们存在之前。所以这真的很让人困惑，我们理性的脑子通常明白把伴侣的过去强加在他们身上是多么不合逻辑，但我们内心总有一个感性的、可以说很脆弱、往往缺乏安全感的部分，就是无法克制。这是一种强迫症。这是一种无意识的感觉和恐惧，害怕他们以前拥有的可能比……
they have now. They know it. They're aware, but you don't. They're having all these private thoughts that you can never fully understand. And that sense that they're a secret. or there is something you can't control in your relationship results in a lot of unhealthy behaviors. You know, comparison, compulsive snooping, especially online on social media, picking fights, sabotaging the relationship, sarcasm, wanting your partner to constantly prove themselves again and
他们现在拥有的更好。他们知道这一点。他们心知肚明，但你却不知道。他们心里有着所有这些你永远无法完全理解的私密想法。而那种觉得他们藏有秘密的感觉……或者你们的关系中有你无法控制的东西，会导致很多不健康的行径。你知道的，比较、强迫性地窥探，尤其是在网络社交媒体上，挑起争端、破坏感情、冷嘲热讽，希望伴侣不断地、一次又一次地向你证明……
again and again and again that they want you, that the past doesn't matter. When in reality it is still a part of who they are, we have to accept that everything we may feel jealous of, is actually what has brought us together. How could you be where you are right now without all those things having happened? And in a sense, you have those past relationships to be grateful for, but because you are so appreciative of the love you have currently,
他们想要你，过去并不重要。然而现实是，过去仍然是他们一部分人格，我们必须接受：我们可能感到嫉妒的一切，实际上正是将我们凝聚在一起的原因。如果没有所有这些事情的发生，你怎么可能走到今天这一步？从某种意义上说，你应该对过去的那些恋情心存感激，但正因为你如此珍视你目前拥有的爱情，……
and you believe it's so worth protecting, we don't see that for what it is. It's definitely a labyrinth at times, and it's really hard to navigate because a secondary component of this is that we feel a lot of shame. And when we experience shame, this really causes us to suppress the emotion. When we suppress, we know this time and time again.
并且你认为它非常值得守护，以至于我们没有看清它的本质。有时它绝对像个迷宫，而且很难驾驭，因为这其中的第二个因素是我们会感到很多的羞耻感。当我们经历羞耻感时，这确实会导致我们压抑这种情绪。而我们一次又一次地知道，当我们选择压抑时……
Avoidance means that this emotion, this feeling is only going to come back with a vengeance because you haven't properly processed it. So let's talk about how you can actually process your retroactive jealousy today, why it occurs, understanding its origins and what we can do about. it before it ends up perhaps undermining or destroying something really, really precious and really, really good. To begin, retroactive jealousy occurs when we feel threatened by our partner's past romantic relationships. Now, that threat doesn't have to be real. This can be for no reason at all, which I think is actually the most common instance where this occurs. There can be times where
逃避意味着这种情绪、这种感觉只会卷土重来，因为你没有好好处理它。所以今天我们来聊聊你该如何真正处理你的回溯性嫉妒，它为什么会发生，理解它的起源，以及我们能对此做些什么。在它最终可能暗中破坏或摧毁一段非常非常珍贵、非常非常美好的感情之前。首先，当我们感到伴侣过去的情感关系对我们构成威胁时，就会产生回溯性嫉妒。现在，这种威胁不一定是真实的。这可能毫无缘由，我认为这其实是最常见的情况。有时……
this jealousy is triggered by something like an ex reaching back out or some of, some comment or action by your partner that makes you believe they're not fully over this person in the past. But most of the time, I would say the source of our jealousy is internal. It has to do with an internal cue or an internal fear or an internal insecurity that we haven't quite yet expressed or aren't ready to really think about. There are times when you deserve to be jealous. And I think there are times when you deserve to not just be jealous, but angry if your partner does do something to betray your trust. But when it comes to retroactive jealousy, that's not really what we're talking about. Because the things that we are struggling with,
这种嫉妒会被某些事情触发，比如前任重新联系，或者伴侣的一些言论或行为让你觉得他们还没有完全放下过去的那个人。但大多数时候，我要说的是，我们嫉妒的根源是内在的。它与我们尚未完全表达或尚未准备好真正思考的内部线索、内部恐惧或内部不安全感有关。有时候你确实有理由感到嫉妒。我认为有时候，如果你的伴侣做出了背叛你信任的事情，你不仅有理由嫉妒，甚至有理由生气。但说到回溯性嫉妒，这并不是我们真正讨论的重点。因为我们正在苦苦挣扎的事情，……
the things that we feel negative emotions towards are things that are so far in the past that it is not entirely fair to blame your partner. Jealousy is a painful emotion, though, and most of us hate to admit that we've ever felt it, because in many ways I think we conflate jealousy with possessiveness. And we don't want this other person to feel like we are trying to control them or that we don't trust them. You know, I think that that's the really difficult thing is because jealousy, although it's natural, is also very villainized. And it also normally triggers a lot of secondary emotions that we are taught to feel a lot of shame towards to really keep underwraps. things like rage, insecurity, self-doubt, embarrassment.
我们对之抱有负面情绪的事情，已经是很久以前的事了，把责任全怪在伴侣头上并不是十分公平。不过，嫉妒是一种痛苦的情绪，我们大多数人都不愿意承认自己曾有过这种感觉，因为在许多方面，我认为我们将嫉妒与占有欲混为一谈了。我们不希望这个人觉得我们在试图控制他们，或者我们不信任他们。你知道，我认为这真的很困难，因为嫉妒虽然是自然的，但也遭到了极大的污名化。它通常也会引发许多次要情绪，而我们被教导要对这些情绪感到强烈的羞耻，必须把它们深深地藏起来。比如愤怒、不安全感、自我怀疑、尴尬。
And so when we don't have a healthy way of understanding those emotions, it can lead us to project a lot of that anger and insecurity onto our partner, which they probably don't deserve. I think it's so interesting to think of how many relationships could have been saved if people had just had an open conversation about how they were feeling, if they had just been honest about the emotions and the reactions that so many people had told them to be embarrassed about. And because they feel so embarrassed about them, they therefore have no other option other than to come out in other ways that society sometimes says is more acceptable, or society says is less possessive or less crazy. when actually the main emotion here, this jealousy is never addressed and will continue to carry on
所以，当我们没有一种健康的方式来理解这些情绪时，就会导致我们将许多愤怒和不安全感投射到伴侣身上，而他们可能并不该承受这些。我认为思考以下这一点非常有趣：如果人们只是公开坦诚地谈论自己的感受，如果他们只是对那些曾被许多人告知应该感到尴尬的情绪和反应保持诚实，那么有多少感情本可以挽救呢？正因为他们对这些情绪感到无比尴尬，所以他们除了以社会有时认为更能接受的其他方式宣泄之外，别无选择，或者社会认为这样占有欲更少、更不疯狂。但实际上，这里的主要情绪——这种嫉妒从未得到解决，并将继续延续下去……
into other relationships. It's not about the person you're dating. It's about the feeling that you don't have a good grasp on. So some of the key signs that you're experiencing retroactive jealousy are as follows. You ruminate and repeatedly think about your partner's ex or past relationships and you feel incredibly envious when they talk about it. You either don't want to talk about it. You don't want to hear a thing. Even if it's an important part of their past or alternatively, you might frequently ask a lot of intrusive questions about what the sex was like when they said they loved each other for the first time, details of every single element of their relationship, because you feel like if you know this stuff, it's going to be comforting, that it's actually going to make that
进入到其他的感情中。这与你正在约会的人无关。这是关于你没有很好把握住的那种感觉。因此，你正在经历回溯性嫉妒的一些关键迹象如下。你反刍并反复思考伴侣的前任或过去的恋情，当他们谈到这些时，你会感到无比嫉妒。你要么不想谈论它。你什么都不想听。即使这是他们过去的重要部分，或者相反，你可能会经常提出许多侵入性的问题，比如当初的性爱是什么感觉，他们第一次说我爱你是什么时候，你们恋情中每一个细节，因为你觉得如果你知道了这些东西，就会得到安慰，而实际上这会让那种……
feeling a lot worse. You also might continuously compare yourself to their past partners, both physically, but then also in terms of emotionally as well and thinking, what did this person give them that maybe I can't? You wonder what they feel like they're missing, even if they've given you no indication that they are feeling this way. You doubt your partner. You begin to fill in what they're saying with your own version of the truth, a version of the truth that is based on your insecurity that is based on your kind of negative impression of past events when it might actually not have been that way at all, right? And additionally, you lash out as a way to look for reassurance. If you start fights and if you are accusatory, sometimes we have this false belief
感觉变得更糟。你还可能会不断地将自己与他们的前任进行比较，不仅在身体外表上，在情感方面也是如此，并心想：这个人给了他们什么也许我给不了的？你想知道他们觉得自己缺少了什么，即使对方没有表现出任何他们有这种感觉的迹象。你怀疑你的伙伴。你开始用你自己的真实版本来填补他们所说的话，这个真实版本是基于你的不安全感，基于你对过去事件的负面印象，而实际情况可能根本不是那样的，对吧？此外，你还会为了寻求安心而大发雷霆。如果你挑起争端，如果你满腹指责，有时我们会有一种错误的信念……
that how our partner reacts in response is going to make us feel better. Either they will reaffirm your beliefs or disprove them. And therefore it acts as its own form. of reassurance, right? You know, fights always have to have either the, like always have a conclusion, right? Either you end the relationship, you break up, or your partner says enough to you, says something to you that's going to make you feel better. Both of those offer a conclusion to your jealousy in the moment that you may not have been getting elsewhere. You might also find that you experience a decline in your self-confidence as a result, which we never want to see that, because when you don't feel fully yourself with your partner, your connection is going to suffer.
即我们的伴侣随之而来的反应会让我们感觉更好。要么他们会重申你的信念，要么会打破它们。因此，它本身就成了一种求安心的方式，对吧？你知道，争吵总是必须要有——要么像总是有个结局，对吧？要么你结束这段关系，你们分手，要么你的伴侣对你说够了，对你说些能让你感觉好受点的话。这两者都为你在当下可能无法在别处得到的嫉妒提供了一个结局。你可能还会发现，结果导致你的自信心下降，我们绝对不想看到这种情况，因为当你和伴侣在一起时感觉不到百分百的自己时，你们的连结就会受损。
You know, they had a history before you, as unfortunate as it is, we don't all immediately find the one on our first tribe, but I'm sure that you also had a history. You also had a past before them. And all of those past relationships that you had obviously ended for a reason. And that is the same for them. They are with you for a reason. You have to trust that being with you is what they see is the best thing for them, the same way you feel about that. The same way that you wouldn't be in this relationship is if it wasn't good, if you didn't value it. You have to trust that your partner is able to make the best decision for them, the same way that you make the best decisions for you.
你知道，他们在你之前有一段历史，尽管很不幸，我们并不是所有人都能在第一次尝试时就找到真爱，但我确信你也有过一段历史。在他们之前你也有过过去。所有那些你过去的恋情显然都是因为某种原因而结束的。他们也是如此。他们和你在一起是有原因的。你必须相信，和你在一起是他们认为对他们最好的事情，就像你对这件事情的感受一样。就像如果这段感情不好、如果你不珍视它，你就不会身处其中一样。你必须相信你的伴侣能够为他们做出最好的决定，就像你为自己做出最好的决定一样。
Like I said before, it's hard not to let retroactive jealousy get in the way because it does bring a lot of associated shame. And as humans, we are also very protective of our heart. love is a very delicate emotion. It's a very special thing and it's very rare. And so we naturally have an instinctive reaction to be quite defensive and vigilant to outside threats that might jeopardize this valuable thing. And truly, I get it. But it's also really valuable to understand where that comes from. So we're going to talk through four explanations here, past trauma and relationship experiences, overthinking, insecurity, including rejection sensitivity, and finally,
正如我之前所说，很难不让回溯性嫉妒从中作梗，因为它确实带来了很多相关的羞耻感。作为人类，我们也极力保护自己的内心。爱情是一种非常脆弱的情绪。这是一件非常特殊的事情，而且极其罕见。因此，我们自然会产生一种本能的反应，对可能危及这一宝贵事物的外部威胁保持防御和警惕。说实话，我完全理解。但明白这些情绪从何而来也同样非常有价值。所以我们在这里将探讨四种解释：过去的创伤和恋爱经历、过度思考、不安全感（包括拒绝敏感性），以及最后……
self-sabotage. Those are the main reasons or the main factors that contribute to frequent retroactive jealousy. I also want to dispel the idea that if you struggle with feeling jealous about your partner's past, you are somehow toxic or possessive or a bad person, because although I do think that jealousy can reach a very noxious point, I would say that the majority of people are not like this. They are just managing a complex interaction between their anxiety, insecurity, vulnerability, and a host of other factors. And they never act on it in a way that is meant to harm who they are with. They are just confused by emotions that they may not have felt before and are looking for reassurance. So let's talk about where retroactive jealousy comes from.
自我破坏。这些是导致频繁回溯性嫉妒的主要原因或主要因素。我还想消除这样一种观念：如果你一直在为嫉妒伴侣的过去而苦恼，你就莫名其妙地成了有毒的人、占有欲强的人或坏人，因为虽然我认为嫉妒确实会达到一个非常有害的程度，但我想说大多数人并不是这样的。他们只是在应对焦虑、不安全感、脆弱感以及其他诸多因素之间的复杂相互作用。他们绝不会以伤害身边人的方式付诸行动。他们只是被自己可能从未感受过的情绪搞糊涂了，并正在寻求安慰。所以让我们来谈谈回溯性嫉妒究竟源自何处。
We're going to start by looking into past relationship trauma. If you have been hurt in the past by a previous partner, perhaps cheating, whether that was emotional or physical, maybe not respecting your boundaries when it came to their communication with an ex, or being unfaithful in some way, it's hard to not bring this previous experience into your new relationship. Trust is a very fragile thing, and once broken, it's very hard to repair. And that doesn't always just apply to the relationship in which the betrayal of trust occurred. Those wounds carry on with us and they can become apparent in our future relationships. That is because those experiences have, in a way, unconsciously taught us something about what it means to be loved and what it means to be in love.
我们将从研究过去的恋爱创伤开始。如果你过去曾被前任伤害过，也许是遭受背叛，无论是精神上的还是肉体上的，也许是没有尊重你在与前任沟通时的界限，或者是以某种方式不忠，你很难不把这种以前的经历带入到你的新恋情中。信任是一件非常脆弱的事情，一旦打破，就很难修复。这并不总是只适用于发生信任背叛的那段关系。那些伤口会伴随着我们，并且可能会在未来的关系中显现出来。这是因为这些经历在某种程度上无意识地教给我们一些关于被爱和身处爱中的意义。
Even if those lessons are an anomaly or aren't correct, our brain is taking on this past information as a way to help teach it what to do in future instances like this to avoid being hurt. that is especially the case when those experiences are very emotionally salient or painful. If you have been cheated on, if it was happening for months behind your back, our brain pays more attention to the content of these memories to avoid a similar pain from occurring in the future. And what this creates is a type of hypervigilance in which you are constantly on alert for any cues or suggestions or indications that you can be heard again. So in psychology, hypervigilance is basically just being more attuned to information in our
即使这些教训只是特例或并不正确，我们的大脑也会吸收这些过去的信息，以此来教导自己在未来类似情况下该怎么做，从而避免受到伤害。当这些经历在情感上非常显著或痛苦时，情况尤其如此。如果你曾被背叛，如果这种事在你的背后持续了数月之久，我们的大脑就会更加关注这些记忆的内容，以避免未来发生类似的痛苦。而这就造成了一种高度警惕的状态，在这种状态下，你时刻保持警惕，注意任何可能让你再次受到伤害的线索、暗示或迹象。所以在心理学中，高度警惕基本上就是对我们环境中……
environment that might confirm our fears. And it's often a sign of a dysregulated nervous system, but also traumatic events in the past or in severe cases, PTSD. And it causes us to interpret the information that we're being given in a different way in a way that wants us to be able to almost predict a threat. So when your new partner does something that anyone else would see a super normal, like take a phone call outside or text on their phone on the other side of the room or recount some story of an ex. You apply a different meaning to their actions and you interpret that something must be wrong that you have a reason to feel jealous. And if you can't find a present day reason for this, you might look to their past for an explanation. And what emerges is
可能证实我们恐惧的信息更加敏感。这通常是神经系统失调的征兆，但也可能是过去创伤事件的征兆，在严重的情况下则是创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。它导致我们以一种不同的方式去诠释被赋予的信息，这种方式让我们几乎能够预测威胁。因此，当你的新伴侣做出任何其他人看来都极其正常的事情时，比如去外面接个电话、在房间另一头用手机发短信，或者讲述某个前任的故事。你会对他们的行为赋予不同的意义，并将其诠释为肯定出了什么问题，你因此有理由感到嫉妒。如果你找不到现阶段的理由，你可能会从他们的过去中寻找解释。而由此浮现出的便是……
retroactive jealousy. It's important to note here that your mind is just trying to protect you. It's trying to do what it does best, which is to avoid pain, both the physical and the emotional type. But sometimes it also jumps to conclusions with limited information. And a lot of that processing of information is based on biases and disqualification. And distortions that you have developed from past experiences. So cognitive biases are essentially a way in which we process information based on how we've learnt things in the past. So it is honest, it's like an abnormal way of seeing things that isn't based in reality. So the particular bias that we're thinking of here is known as selective perception bias whereby our expectations. We're by our expectations,
回溯性嫉妒。这里需要注意的是，你的大脑只是在试图保护你。它在试图做它最擅长的事情，那就是避免痛苦，包括身体上和情感上的。但有时候它也会在信息有限的情况下妄下结论。而许多此类信息处理都是基于偏见和取消资格。以及你从过去的经历中发展出来的扭曲心理。因此，认知偏分本质上是我们根据过去学习事物的方式处理信息的一种方式。所以它是真实的，这就像是一种不基于现实的、看待事物的异常方式。所以我们这里想到的特定偏见被称为选择性知觉偏误，即我们的期望……
determine what we actually end up seeing. And what we tend to miss is all the other information that is telling us we have nothing to worry about. We don't always think about the reassurance. All the moments that our partner has told us that they do love us, that they want to be with us, the little things they do for us. Instead, the focus remains on the past because that is where we see the danger as being.
决定了我们最终实际看到的内容。而我们往往忽略的是所有其他告诉我们无需担心、我们一切正常的信息。我们并不总是去想那些让人安心的事。伴侣告诉我们他们确实爱我们、他们想和我们在一起的所有时刻，以及他们为我们做的小事。相反，重点仍然停留在过去，因为那是我们看到危险所在的地方。
that is where we see there being perhaps a threat to our relationship. And it's important to remember that a lot of this anxiety and worry is irrational. And also just a natural reaction to uncertainty and putting yourself in a position where you know you could get hurt. That's really what it is at the end of the day. Like love provides a lot of opportunity to get seriously heartbroken. And that is something that none of us are going to opt into. none of us want to feel.
那是我们看到可能对我们的关系构成威胁的地方。重要的是要记住，许多这样的焦虑和担忧是不理性的。这也只是对不确定性以及让自己处于明知可能会受伤的位置的一种自然反应。归根结底，这确实就是这么回事。比如爱情提供了很多心碎的机会。而这是我们谁都不会主动选择的。没有人愿意感受这种情绪。
And so all of these thoughts, all of this jealousy is really just a way for you to ensure that you could predict if that was going to happen and to be on the lookout for any signs of danger to your relationship. I think though part of love, however, is that you just have to trust this other person won't do that. And trusting them also deepens the bond in many ways. So the second major reason that we tend to experience retrogressions. act of jealousy is related to overthinking. A lot of individuals who are naturally very anxious
因此，所有这些想法、所有这些嫉妒，实际上只是你确保自己能够预测这种情况是否会发生，并时刻留意对你的关系构成威胁的任何迹象的一种方式。不过，我认为爱情的一部分在于，你只需要相信这个人不会那样做。在许多方面，信任他们也会加深你们之间的纽带。因此，我们往往会经历回溯性嫉妒的第二个主要原因与过度思考有关。许多天生非常焦虑的人……
also have the tendency to overthink and ruminate on things beyond their control, because the very act of thinking about these things repetitively brings about a sense of false security. If we can imagine every possible situation, everything our partner is not telling us every way we might not be as good as the ex, every way that they might want more, we can prepare ourselves for when those fears inevitably are proven true. Even though we know that they probably never will. That's not the point, right? We don't actually want the thoughts and the fears to come true, but we just want to be prepared just in case they do. O overthinking really plays a big part in the obsessive nature of retroactive jealousy
也倾向于过度思考和反刍那些超出他们控制范围的事情，因为反复思考这些事情的行为本身就会带来一种虚假的安全感。如果我们能想象出每一种可能的情况、伴侣没有告诉我们的每一件事、我们在哪些方面可能不如前任、他们在哪些方面可能想要更多，我们就能在这些恐惧不可避免地被证实为真时做好准备。尽管我们知道它们可能永远不会成真。重点不在这里，对吧？我们其实并不希望那些想法和恐惧成真，我们只是想以防万一做好准备。过度思考在回溯性嫉妒的强迫性本质中确实扮演了重要角色……
because there will never be a conclusion or an answer that is going to satisfy us whilst we are in that thought spiral, because as soon as one door closes, another one will open. That is the nature of overthinking. Normally, I would say in someone's brain, what mindy-coa is that a thought pops into your head, one of the millions, perhaps billions of thoughts that we have in a day. But this one feels really scary because it's about someone that you care about. It may be a thought like, does my boyfriend find,
因为当我们陷入这种思维漩涡时，永远不会有一个能让我们满意的结论或答案，因为一扇门刚关上，另一扇门就会打开。这就是过度思考的本质。通常，我想在某个人的脑海里，一个想法会突然跳出来，比如我们在一天中产生的数百万甚至数十亿个想法之一。但这个想法感觉非常吓人，因为它是关于一个你在乎的人。这可能是一个这样的想法：我的男朋友觉得……
me as attractive as his ex. Now, most people can dismiss this thought and realize that it's fear-based and irrational and just be like, yeah, of course he does. And even if he doesn't, that's not my problem. Like, whatever, it's okay. I know that we're in love. I know that we're okay. But if you are a natural overthinker, any thought of this kind that has that emotional magnitude behind it requires close examination because you aren't comfortable unless you know for a fact that it's untrue. So you obsess on it, you let it simmer, which causes the thought spiral to continue. What you're really struggling with is the uncertainty. There is so much about a relationship that you can't control.
我像他的前任一样迷人吗。现在，大多数人可以打消这个念头，意识到这是基于恐惧且不理性的，然后就会想：是的，他当然觉得。即使他没有，那也不是我的问题。管他呢，没关系。我知道我们在恋爱。我知道我们很好。但如果你是一个天生的过度思考者，任何带有这种情感分量的此类想法都需要仔细审视，因为除非你确切知道这不是真的，否则你不会安心。所以你对此魂牵梦绕，任由它发酵，从而导致思维漩涡持续下去。你真正与之抗争的是不确定性。一段关系中有太多东西是你无法控制的。
You can't control someone's private thoughts, you can't control their feelings, and you definitely can't control their past. This acknowledgement breeds a lot of insecurity, a lot of instability, and it can also culminate in something that we call retroactive OCD, a type of honestly obsessive compulsive disorder that involves becoming super overwhelmed by intrusive thoughts of a partner's past such that we can't even control their frequency, their quantity, their intensity. We don't want to feel this way and the more you struggle against it, the louder some of those thoughts become because they gain a lot more
你无法控制一个人的私密想法，你无法控制他们的感情，你也绝对无法控制他们的过去。这种承认孕育了大量的不安全感、极大的不稳定，并且还可能最终演变成我们所说的回溯性强迫症（ROC D），这是一种老实说属于强迫症的心理障碍，涉及被伴侣过去的侵入性想法压得喘不过气来，以至于我们甚至无法控制它们的频率、数量和强度。我们不想有这种感觉，你越是与之抗争，其中一些想法的声音就越响亮，因为它们对你获得了……
power over you. It may also have to do with a level of personal insecurity, perhaps insecurity about your value as a partner, your attractiveness, your intelligence, your past sexual experience. I see this a lot with partners where one partner has had more sexual partners than the other. It feels like because they have more comparison points, because maybe they've had more casual sex, they've had more experience, whatever it may be, that this other person can't live up to what they had in the past and therefore they can't be the best. So they'll always, this other person will always want something more than them. They'll want something better. And that is what really breeds this jealousy. Now, this is entirely untrue. What's actually happening here is that we are experiencing
更大的掌控力。这可能也与个人不安全感的程度有关，也许是对你作为伴侣的价值、你的吸引力、你的智力、你过去的性经验感到不安全。我在伴侣身上经常看到这种情况，其中一方的性伴侣比另一方多。感觉就像是因为他们有更多的对比点，也许是因为他们有过更多随意的性行为，有过更多经验，无论可能是什么原因，这个人无法达到他们过去所拥有的水平，因此他们不可能是最好的。所以他们会永远，这个人会永远想要比他们更多的东西。他们会想要更好的东西。而这正是孕育这种嫉妒的根源。现在，这完全不是真的。这里真正发生的是，我们正在经历……
a deflation in our self-esteem based on something someone else can't even control, i.e. a past event. And we are using that event. We're using our partner's past as almost a projection of, of how we're feeling deep inside, which is that we're not feeling amazing, we're searching for a reason why we're not feeling amazing, and when it comes to our partner's X, that feels like the perfect point to diffuse all of our insecurity. A study published by the American Psychological Association actually found a pretty significant link between jealousy and low self-esteem, especially when it comes to sexual jealousy. Here's the thing. I don't think that you should be ashamed of your insecurities because you really didn't have a choice in the matter. There is not a
基于别人甚至无法控制的事情（即过去的事件）的自尊心贬低。我们正在利用那个事件。我们几乎将伴侣的过去当作我们内心深处感受的一种投射，那就是我们感觉不佳，我们正在寻找为什么自己感觉不佳的原因，而当谈到伴侣的前任时，这似乎是宣泄我们所有不安全感的完美宣泄口。美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）发表的一项研究实际上发现，嫉妒与低自尊之间存在着相当显著的联系，特别是在涉及性嫉妒时。事情是这样的。我认为你不应该为自己的不安全感感到羞耻，因为在这件事上你真的别无选择。没有一个……
single person who would choose to feel less than or who would choose to be inadequate when given the choice. But although you don't have control over how your insecurity has come to be, your origin story, you do have a choice on how you choose to communicate your insecurity to your partner. is that through sarcasm or picking fights or the silent treatment or is it about doing what is objectively harder but better overall which is being honest with them letting them see this part of you this fragile element of you that is causing a lot of that anger and sadness over the past when this insecurity is left unchecked it can also reveal itself through self-sabotage when we don't feel good enough this can unconsciously inform how we choose to act
人在有选择的情况下会选择自我感觉不如人或感觉自己不够优秀。尽管你无法控制你的不安全感是如何产生的，即你的起源故事，但你可以选择如何将你的不安全感传达给伴侣。是通过冷嘲热讽、挑起争端还是冷暴力，或者是去做客观上更难但总体上更好的事情，也就是对他们坦诚相待，让他们看到你这部分脆弱的元素，而正是这部分元素导致了对过去的许多愤怒和悲伤。当这种不安全感任由其发展时，它也可能通过自我破坏表现出来。当我们感觉自己不够好时，这会无意识地影响我们如何选择行动……
manifesting in behaviors that we know will push our partner away, like invading their privacy, like picking fights, like continuously coming back to this intrusive thought. We know what will come of those behaviors. The outcome is predictable. They will probably leave us. The relationship will break down. But at least in some strange way, you had a say in it. It feels like you're bringing the consistent.
表现为我们知道会把伴侣推开的行为，比如侵犯他们的隐私、挑起争端、不断回到这个侵入性的想法中。我们知道这些行为会带来什么结果。结果是可以预见的。他们可能会离开我们。关系会破裂。但至少在某种奇怪的方面，你在这件事上有发言权。这感觉就像是通过把他们推开，而不是坐等他们因为一些你无法预测的事情（比如对前任或某段感情过去的感情等）而离去，从而将持续的……
control back to you by pushing them away rather than waiting for them to walk away based on something that you can't predict like past feelings about an ex or a relationship or whatever it is. You just truly are trying to sabotage the relationship as a way to not be blindsided when you believe it will inevitably come to an end. Self-sabotage has its origins and that insecurity we were speaking about before and it's a coping mechanism we use to bring about a sense of agency in situations where we don't feel a lot of agency or security, but also to manage stressful situations and past trauma. So it does go hand in hand with retroactive jealousy quite a bit. There are a few other factors that contribute to this form of jealousy, including a big one,
控制权重新交回你手中。你其实只是在试图破坏这段关系，以此作为一种方式，在当你相信这段关系不可避免地走向终点时，不至于被打个措手不及。自我破坏起源于我们之前谈到的那种不安全感，这是我们在缺乏代理感或安全感的环境中用来获得代理感的一种应对机制，同时也是为了应对压力情境和过去的创伤。所以它确实与回溯性嫉妒息息相关。还有一些其他因素导致了这种形式的嫉妒，其中一个重大因素是……
an anxious attachment style. We know that that contributes to a significant fear of abandonment and rejection and therefore possibly a hyperfixation on our partner's past relationships. And then also rejection sensitivity, being particularly perceptive and sensitive, susceptible to indications that someone is going to reject you, one of which could be, of course, this is not true, but it could be their past. So you remain very focused on it. I'm really trying to make this point. A lot of this is coming from a place of fear, and fear is most of the time very irrational and untrue. But all of this can really take its toll, especially for your partner as well, it's important to understand that they can also feel
焦虑型依恋风格。我们知道这会导致对被抛弃和拒绝的极大恐惧，因此可能导致对伴侣过去恋情的过度关注。还有拒绝敏感性，即对有人会拒绝你的迹象特别敏锐、敏感、易受影响，其中之一当然这不是真的，但可能是他们的过去。所以你依然高度专注于此。我真的很想强调这一点。这一切很大程度上都源于恐惧，而恐惧在大多数时候都是非常不理性且不真实的。但这一切确实会付出沉重的代价，特别是对你的伴侣来说也是如此，理解他们也能感受到……
a lot of the emotional consequences of this. They can feel shame over their own past. They can feel like there's nothing they can say or do that will help you. They can be a lot of frustration at the repetitive nature of your arguments. And frustration that you don't believe them when they say those people really mean nothing to them now. Some therapists might suggest to you that a bit of jealousy is helpful. One of those people is a very renowned psychotherapist Esther Perel. She talks about this theory, this idea in her book, mating in captivity, and according to her jealousy, proves to us and our partner that we care, that we want to stay committed to someone, and that we realize that we have a good thing. So in that way, it's very positive, because if you never felt
这带来许多情感后果是很重要的。他们可能会对自己过去的经历感到羞耻。他们可能会觉得没有什么话可说或没有什么事可做能帮到你。他们可能会对你们争吵的重复性质感到非常沮丧。而且因为你不相信他们说那些人现在对他们来说真的毫无意义而感到沮丧。一些治疗师可能会向你建议，一点点嫉妒是有帮助的。其中一位是著名的心理治疗师埃丝特·佩瑞尔（Esther Perel）。她在她的书《繁殖在囚笼中》（Mating in Captivity）中谈到了这个理论，这个观点，根据她的说法，嫉妒向我们和我们的伴侣证明了我们在乎，我们想要对某人保持忠诚，并且我们意识到我们拥有美好的事物。从这个意义上说，这是非常积极的，因为如果你从未感到过……
threatened, even at times when you should, it might indicate that you're not all in. Now, I will say that this is just one perspective. It's not for everyone. And obviously, it is somewhat controversial at times. I, for one, do believe that a bit of jealousy does actually affirm your trust in someone and helps you realize again and again that they will choose you. But when it's rampant, when you have no control over it, when we are in a state that no love or reassurance can calm us, this will put a strain on your relationship. And it could cause you to lose a very good thing. So let's talk about how to manage our retroactive jealousy and process all the causes, the contributors that are keeping us in a position of feeling very powerless and out of
威胁，甚至在有时你本该感到威胁的时候，这可能表明你并非全身心投入。现在，我要说这只是一个视角。它并不适合所有人。而且很显然，有时它多少有些争议。我个人确实认为，一点点嫉妒确实可以肯定你对某人的信任，并帮你一次又一次地意识到他们会选择你。但当它泛滥成灾，当你无法控制它时，当我们处于任何爱或安慰都无法让我们平静的状态时，这就会给你的关系带来压力。并且可能导致你失去一件非常美好的事物。所以让我们来谈谈如何管理我们的回溯性嫉妒，并处理所有保持我们在自己的关系中感到非常无力、失控的原因和诱因。
control in our own relationship. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
所有这些以及更多精彩内容，稍后回来。百分之二。这是有电梯可坐时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，欢迎收听我的播客《百分之二》。在这个光怪陆离的现代世界里，我将为你剖析心理韧性、健身以及培养抗逆力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带你超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上有炎症。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《百分之二》。认准数字“2”percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾往昔》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，1984年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为犯罪。还有快克可卡因。我不介意在节目里聊聊快克，但为了让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾往昔》。
Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month,
欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难求知》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖姆斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我指的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们甚至不知道……
when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
什么时候才算真正做够了。因为人们总在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是这样。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search, learn the hard way, and listen now.
这两种信任的层面是不同的。我只希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我和我（科尔·盖恩斯）的新播客《从难中学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我们将共同进行关于疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标的真实对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索 Learn the Hard Way，立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战，旨在证明真相。“你在这个特定的测试中造假了两次，对吧？”“我篡改了一次测试。”这需要一群网络侦探来破解这个案子。“我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。”“阳光是最好的消毒剂。”
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You want your relationship to last. It is important to reaffirm that as much as possible.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。你希望你的关系持久。尽可能多地重申这一点是很重要的。
If you are not committed, first, like you probably wouldn't be listening to this episode. You wouldn't be having these concerns because you wouldn't be worried about having something to lose. The thing is, though, you can't choose. your partner, the person that is the most important person in your life, based on their past, because that is going to really, really limit your options and mean that you could potentially miss out on your soulmate just because they've had a few too many axes. They had a past, so did you, and you need to remember that all those relationships ended for a reason. They have
如果你没有坚定的承诺，首先，你可能就不会收听这一集。你不会有这些担忧，因为你不会担心失去什么。然而，问题在于，你不能根据你的伴侣（你生命中最重要的人）的过去来选择他们，因为这会真真切切地极大地限制你的选择，这意味着你可能会与你的灵魂伴侣擦肩而过，只因为他们有过几个前任。他们有过去，你也有，你需要记住，所有这些关系结束都是有原因的。他们有
free will. Your partner has free will. They are making the best decision for them, and that is to be with you. They want to be here. I always find it valuable to think about how I feel about my own exes. Quite frankly, I want nothing to do with them. And if that's how I feel, why wouldn't my partner feel the same way about their past? Secondly, would you really want to date someone who had zero experience with dating, with emotional intimacy, who had never experienced love or heartbreak or what it had to teach you? I don't necessarily think that I would. I feel like that would be equally as strange to me to feel like I was the one who's having to show them everything
自由意志。你的伴侣有自由意志。他们正在做出对他们而言最好的决定，那就是和你在一起。他们想留在这里。我总是觉得思考我对自己的前任的感受很有价值。坦白说，我和他们没有任何关系。如果这就是我的感受，为什么我的伴侣对他们的过去就不会有同样的感受呢？其次，你真的想和这样一个毫无恋爱经验、没有经历过情感亲密、从未体验过爱情或心碎、或者不知道这些能教会你什么的人约会吗？我并不一定觉得我会愿意。我觉得这对我来说同样会很奇怪，感觉自己好像是那个不得不向他们展示一切的人，
that had to be their first love when I'd had loves in the past as well. So I think that we always think that we would prefer something else, the grass being greener on the other side, but actually what you have right now is probably pretty, pretty good. and it's just this small insecurity that you're going to have to move past. You can let yourself be ruled by fear, or you can decide to just give in to this anxiety.
他们必须是我的初夜，而我自己过去也曾有过爱。所以我想我们总是认为我们会更喜欢别的东西，也就是“邻家的草更绿”，但实际上你现在拥有的可能已经非常、非常好了，这只是一个小小的 insecurity（不安全感），你需要克服它。你可以让自己被恐惧支配，或者你可以决定向这种焦虑妥协。
I find that retroactive jealousy is almost like quicksand. The more you struggle against it and suppress your feelings, refuse to speak them out loud, the more you fight and fight and fight against your jealousy, the more entrenched you become, the more you sink. Instead, you have to do what feels, insanely counterintuitive in the moment, which is to just let yourself feel what you're feeling without trying to escape from it, without trying to assign some deeper meaning to your emotions.
我发现恋旧嫉妒（retroactive jealousy）几乎就像流沙。你越是与它抗争并压抑自己的感受，拒绝大声说出来，你越是与你的嫉妒心进行斗争、斗争、再斗争，你就会陷得越深，下沉得越多。相反，你必须做一件在当时感觉极其违反直觉的事，那就是让自己去感受你的感受，而不要试图逃避，也不要试图给你的情绪赋予某种更深层的意义。
You are not your thoughts, you are separate from your thoughts, your thoughts do not predict the future, you are just receiving those thoughts, you can't control what pops into your head and having these thoughts doesn't make you a bad person. It doesn't mean that your relationship is doomed to fail. It doesn't say anything about your relationship other than that. Perhaps you just have something to work through. This is this idea of cognitive diffusion, being able to look at your thoughts and just observe them rather than panic at them.
你不是你的思想，你独立于你的思想之外，你的思想无法预知未来，你只是在接收这些思想。你无法控制脑海中突然蹦出的念头，有这些想法并不意味着你是个坏人，也不意味着你的感情注定会失败。除了这一点，它无法说明关于你们关系的任何事情，也许你只是有些心结需要解开。这就是认知解离的概念，能够审视自己的思想并只是观察它们，而不是对它们感到恐慌。
I think that our experience with retroactive jealousy becomes a lot easier when you just see your thoughts as just these little things popping in to say hi, that aren't going to hurt you, that don't mean really anything other than that they just exist, that they're just background noise. You're allowed to ignore those thoughts. You are allowed to ignore the thoughts that are not useful for you that are not productive to you,
我认为，当你把自己的想法看作是那些突然跳出来打个招呼的小东西时，你对回溯性嫉妒的体验会变得轻松很多。它们不会伤害你，除了它们确实存在之外，并没有什么真正的含义，它们只是背景噪音。你可以忽略这些想法。你可以忽略那些对你没有用处、对你没有建设性的想法，
and kind of accept the fact that they are not there to help you. They are coming from a place of insecurity, of anxiety, of overthinking, and the more you feed into them, the harder it's going to be to find a conclusion or to find an answer that's actually going to make you feel better. It's part of that acceptance of the fact that you're never going to have full clarity about your partner's past. You can think up a million different scenarios, but none of them are actually going to be true. And all of them are probably going to make you feel a lot worse. I just have this belief that sometimes you do just have to have blind faith in what someone else is saying to you. If they say you have nothing to worry about, don't try and argue with them.
并接受这样一个事实：它们并不是来帮你的。它们源于不安全感、焦虑和过度思考，你越是纠结于它们，就越难找到一个能让你真正感觉好点的方法或答案。这就需要接受这样一个事实：你永远无法对伴侣的过去有百分之百的清晰了解。你可以构想出一百万种不同的情景，但没有一个是真实的。而且所有这些情景可能都会让你感觉更糟。我只是有这样一种信念，有时候你确实必须对别人对你说的话盲目信任。如果他们说你没什么好担心的，就不要试图去和他们争论。
Just say, okay, yeah, I choose to believe you. I'm choosing to believe you, even if I don't want to, even if my fear wants me to look for another answer. I'm not going to look. Maybe you're lying to me, but, you know, it's about trusting that you've also got a very good judge of character and you've chosen a good person to be in your life who is not going to lie to you, who is not going to deceive you, who wants to be here with you now in this relationship. So saying to yourself, okay, I'm just going to believe this person kind of lets your anxiety and overthinking know where you stand. It shows them that you are the bus, you have set a boundary
只需说，好吧，是的，我选择相信你。我选择相信你，即使我内心并不想这样，即使我的恐惧促使我去寻找另一个答案。我不会去找的。也许你在对我说谎，但你知道，这是关于相信你也有很好的看人眼光，你选择了一个好人进入你的生活，他不会对你撒谎，不会欺骗你，他现在想和你在一起，在这个关系里。所以对自己说，好吧，我只要相信这个人，就能让你的焦虑和过度思考知道你的立场。这向它们表明你是掌控者，你已经给自己设定了一条界限，
with yourself, you're giving yourself permission to stop ruminating. The other biggest gift you can give yourself in those moments is to eliminate any of the behaviour. behavioral compulsions, which you know are going to elicit a really emotional reaction. I'm talking about stalking their exes, stalking their old tagged photos, asking endless questions of your partner about their ex, information that you quite frankly do not need to know. Now, I'm using the word compulsion here because that is what they are. They're very difficult to suppress, especially when we have perhaps gotten used to feeling an anxious thought, feeling compelled to act in a certain way, and receiving some momentary
你允许自己停止反刍。在那些时刻，你能给自己的另一个最大礼物就是消除任何行为冲动，你知道这些冲动会引发强烈的情绪反应。我说的是窥探他们的前任，窥探他们以前被标记的照片，没完没了地向伴侣盘问关于他们前任的事，而这些信息坦白说你根本不需要知道。现在，我在这里使用了“冲动”这个词，因为它们就是这样。它们很难压抑，尤其是当我们可能已经习惯了产生焦虑的想法，感到被迫以某种方式行事，并获得某种暂时的
reassurance, but it just means that the next time you need reassurance, the threshold is higher. And you actually aren't learning how to control those unconscious spikes of jealousy. You're allowing them to be kind of fueled by all of these behaviors that are giving you just more information that could potentially hurt your feelings, more information that you need to put it and find a way to fit into your brain, more scenarios to play with. You are just adding more fuel to the fire essentially. And we need to approach this on a need to know basis. If it doesn't impact your current relationship, you quite frankly don't need to know. It's okay. You don't need to know everything. The uncertainty that you're feeling in response to that is just a feeling.
安慰时，但这只意味着下次你需要安慰时，门槛会更高。而且你实际上并没有学会如何控制那些无意识的嫉妒心。你任由这些行为火上浇油，它们只会给你提供更多可能伤害你感情的信息，提供更多你需要强行塞进大脑并找出办法去适应的信息，以及更多可以拿来演绎的情景。本质上，你只是在火上浇油。我们需要根据实际需要来处理这个问题。如果它不影响你们目前的关系，坦白说你根本不需要知道。没关系，你不需要知道所有事情。对此你所感受到的不确定性只是一种感觉。
You will never know everything. So perhaps if you'll never know everything, it's better. it alone to know, you know, less rather than more. It's also important to remember that your version of your partner's past might not be theirs. You are creating this mental movie that is probably totally different from reality, totally different to how it actually was. And it is a mental image, a mental movie that is most certainly leveraging your fears rather than the truth. It wants to be extreme. It is extrapolating based on limited information in a manner that our brain thinks will protect us
你永远不可能了解所有事情。所以也许既然你无法了解一切，最好还是顺其自然，知道得少一点总比多一点好。同样重要的是要记住，你所认为的伴侣的过去可能并不是他们的真实经历。你正在脑海中创作这部电影，它可能与现实完全不同，与当时的情况完全不同。这是一个脑海中的画面、脑海中的电影，它绝对是在利用你的恐惧而非真相。它想要走极端。它根据有限的信息进行外推，这种方式我们的大脑以为是在保护我们，
but is really harming us and probably lying to us as well. So it's important to counteract those thoughts that have no evidence to them. Has your partner given you any indication that they don't want to be with you? No. Have they ever said that they want to get back with their ex? No. Have they showed you any information? indication, a reasonable indication that they wanted to? Probably not. Question the validity of your
但实际上却在伤害我们，可能还在对我们撒谎。因此，抵制那些毫无依据的想法非常重要。你的伴侣有没有表现出任何不想和你在一起的迹象？没有。他们有没有说过想和前任复合？没有。他们有没有向你透露任何信息？有迹象表明他们想这样做吗？大概没有。质疑你的
fearful thoughts. Now, obviously the example that we are mostly relying on are occasions where you actually don't have anything to worry about. I would say though that if there are boundaries that are being crossed, that is giving you a reason to feel jealous and to feel really terrible, if you feel like this person that you're dating or this person that you're with is encouraging that reaction almost as like a self-esteem boost to them. This does not apply. Everything we've spoken about does not apply. That person is not good for you. You should have a serious conversation with them about why they feel the need to do that, why they are crossing boundaries that you have set for yourself, why they are choosing to disrespect you, and find out whether that's something
恐惧想法的有效性。现在，很明显，我们主要依赖的例子是那些你实际上无需担忧的情况。不过我想说的是，如果有些界限被逾越了，这确实给了你理由去感到嫉妒和极度糟糕，如果你觉得你约会的人或你在一起的人几乎是在鼓励这种反应，以此来提升他们自己的自尊心。这种情况则不适用。我们所谈论的一切都不适用。那个人对你不好。你应该和他们进行一次严肃的谈话，谈谈他们为什么觉得有必要这样做，为什么他们要践踏你为自己设定的底线，为什么他们选择不尊重你，并弄清楚这是否是你可以
that you're going to be willing to work with them towards fixing, or whether this relationship perhaps is not the one for you. Because sometimes you realize that you're actually not crazy. And I'm going to say crazy in quotation marks. You are not the crazy girlfriend or the crazy partner or the crazy boyfriend. You are actually with someone who is manipulating your emotions for their own personal gain and for their own sense of confidence and sense of self-esteem. I've had that in the past where this person liked seeing me get jealous in a weird, twisted way,
和他们一起努力去解决的事情，或者这段关系也许并不适合你。因为有时你会意识到自己其实并没有疯。我要把“疯”字加上引号。你不是那个疯狂的女朋友、疯狂的伴侣或疯狂的男朋友。你其实是和一个为了个人利益、个人自信心和自尊心而操纵你情绪的人在一起。我过去也有过这样的经历，这个人以一种奇怪、扭曲的方式喜欢看我嫉妒，
because every time I got jealous, he got the reassurance that I wanted to be with him. When I was telling him again and again and again that I did, but the jealousy was like this extra cherry on top, and it was so infuriating when I kind of began to realize that that was what he was doing because it was not a pleasant emotion, and it was, putting such a strain on our relationship and causing us to fight all the time, causing me to feel like I wasn't the person I wanted to be in that relationship. So I'm going to say an important caveat here if you're with someone who is deliberately creating feelings of jealousy or who is not respecting your boundaries, who is communicating with their ex regularly and has no need to,
因为每次我嫉妒时，他都会得到“我还想和他在一起”的这种心理安慰。当我一次又一次地告诉他我的确想和他在一起，但嫉妒就像是蛋糕上多出来的樱桃时，当我开始意识到这就是他在做的事情时，我是如此愤怒，因为这不是一种愉快的体验，这给我们的关系带来了巨大的压力，导致我们一直在争吵，让我觉得自己在这段关系中不是我想成为的那个人。所以我要在这里说一个重要的警告：如果你和某人在一起，而这个人是故意制造嫉妒的感觉，或者不尊重你的底线，经常与前任联系且根本没有必要，
maybe that's not the right relationship for you. Maybe you're not the problem. In those other instances, though, that we were speaking about where it really is just a deep insecurity and overthinking, I would say try not to involve your partner too much in helping you to solve this problem, in helping you to address your retroactive jealousy. They can, of course, be a teammate, but they can't be your coach because then we often become too overly reliant on their reassurance, rather than actually addressing the root cause of this problem, which is that past trauma, perhaps, maybe that lack of security in your relationship, that insecurity, the overthinking, the self-sabotage, those are all things that
也许那并不是一段适合你的关系。也许问题不在于你。不过，在我们刚才谈到的其他情况下，如果真的只是因为深层的不安全感和过度思考，我想说，尽量不要让你的伴侣过多地参与到帮助你解决这个问题、帮助你应对回溯性嫉妒中来。他们当然可以成为队友，但他们不能成为你的教练，因为这样我们往往会过度依赖他们的安慰，而不是去解决这个问题的根本原因——也就是过去的创伤，也许是对关系的缺乏安全感，那种不安全感，过度思考，自我破坏，所有这些
your partner actually can't help you with. You'll have to do that on your own. And putting too much pressure on them to constantly make you feel better only just exacerbates and continues the cycle of retroactive jealousy, never actually causing you to pull yourself out of those of that thought pattern and think about the why rather than the current present moment and the what and thinking about what can make you feel better why not think about how can I stop this from occurring in the first place perhaps that is really going to therapy and breaking down the content of those harmful memories from the past what wounds are you carrying from past relationships that are showing up in your current relationship. Maybe that is focusing on working on your own insecurity.
其实是你的伴侣无法帮你的。你必须靠自己去做到这一点。给他们施加太大的压力，让他们不断让你感觉好点，只会加剧并延续回溯性嫉妒的循环，让你永远无法真正把自己从那种思维模式中拉出来，去思考“为什么”，而不是只盯着当前的时刻和“是什么”，去思考怎样才能让自己感觉好点，为什么不思考“我如何才能从一开始就阻止这种事情发生”呢？也许这才是真正的去看心理医生，剖析过去那些痛苦记忆的内容，弄清楚你带着来自过去关系的什么伤痛，而这些伤痛正显现在你当前的关系中。也许这应该专注于克服你自己的不安全感。
Why don't you feel adequate? Is it because you have never felt particularly confident about your body? Is it because you lack the same amount of experience as this person? Is it because you feel like you're not in their league or some other made-up idea or basis for weighing and judging attractiveness. Instead of focusing on those things, and this is such a basic introduction to addressing insecurity that requires a whole episode of its own, but instead of focusing on all the ways that you may not be as good as their ex, that they may be better than you, that they may be deserving of more, focus on what you're amazing at. You are excellent at something. I'm sure of you excel at many things. There is a reason that this person has chosen you, even if you are
你为什么觉得自己不够好？是因为你从来没有对自己的身材感到特别自信吗？是因为你缺乏和这个人相当的经验吗？是因为你觉得自己配不上他，还是因为有其他凭空捏造的想法或衡量吸引力的标准？与其把焦点放在这些事情上（这只是应对不安全感的一个非常基础的引言，需要一整集节目来专门探讨），不如把焦点放在所有你可能不如他的前任、他们可能比你优秀、他们可能值得拥有更好的地方，转而关注你擅长的领域。你在某些方面非常优秀。我确信你在很多事情上都很出色。这个人选择你是有原因的，即使你现在
struggling to see it right now. You have so much love to give. You are such a generous person. I'm sure that you are very, very kind, or I would like to assume so, very intelligent. There are so many attributes that I think we ignore because we want to pretend that we're humble or because we don't want to feel immodest or arrogant. And really, that can actually just contribute to us not feeling like we have any value at all. Get back in touch with the things that make you unique and interesting and incredible and worthy of love such that you don't need to be comparing yourself to this person's ex or their past flings or situationships because you are wholly confident that what you have is better, what you have with them is better. Now,
很难看到这一点。你拥有如此多的爱可以付出。你是一个如此慷慨的人。我确信你非常非常善良，或者我愿意这样假设，而且非常聪明。我们有很多属性，我认为我们之所以会忽略它们，是因为我们想假装谦虚，或者因为我们不想显得不谦虚或傲慢。而实际上，这可能恰恰导致我们觉得自己毫无价值。重新找回那些让你变得独特、有趣、不可思议且值得被爱的特质，这样你就不需要拿自己去和这个人的前任、他们的过去或是暧昧对象进行比较，因为你完全坚信你所拥有的更好，你与他们所拥有的更好。好了，
I think that's all we have time for today. I really hope that this episode has provided you with something to think about, has helped you if you are dealing with retroactive jealousy. I didn't want to approach this with too much shame because I know sometimes we can really get confused when it comes to this form of jealousy and think that it means that we're possessive or that we're all these number of bad things when actually I do just think that it comes from a lot of hurt that we need to heal. Retroactive jealousy is just a sign of some internal damage or some internal insecurity that our mind is calling on us to address. So I'm sending you a lot of love. This is a lot more common than you think. So you are not
我想今天的时间就到这里了。我真心希望这一集能给你们带来一些思考，能对正在应对回溯性嫉妒的你们有所帮助。我不想用过多的羞耻感来探讨这个问题，因为我知道有时我们在面对这种形式的嫉妒时确实会感到困惑，会认为这意味着我们有占有欲，或者意味着我们有种种不好的特质，但实际上我真的认为它源于我们需要治愈的许多创伤。回溯性嫉妒只是一些内在损伤或内在不安全感的信号，我们的大脑在呼唤我们去解决它们。所以我向你们发送许多爱。这种情况比你想象的要普遍得多，所以你并不是
alone in this feeling. You are not a bad person because you ruminate on somebody else's past, but you do have a responsibility to yourself and to your relationship, to your partner, to the person that you want to be with to get to the root cause of why this is occurring. It will take hard work. It will take a lot of honesty and vulnerability. But once you do that, I think you eradicate a lot of the negativity that is making you feel shameful about yourself or making you feel, making you question the state of your relationship. So thank you so much for listening. If there is someone that you believe needs to hear this episode, please feel free to share it with them and leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, whatever you are listening right now. If you have
一个人在经历这种感受。你并不是一个坏人，因为你在反复琢磨别人的过去，但你确实对自己、对你的关系、对你的伴侣、对你想与之共度一生的人负有责任，去找出这一切发生的根本原因。这需要付出努力。这需要大量的诚实和脆弱。但一旦你做到了这一点，我认为你就消除了许多让你对产生羞耻感、或者让你质疑自己感情状态的负面情绪。非常感谢大家的收听。如果你认为有人需要收听这一集，请随时与他们分享，并在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你目前正在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。如果你有
an episode suggestion, this episode was actually an episode suggestion, please feel free to message me at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram, or you can follow me at Jemis Beck. If you have any ideas for upcoming episodes, topics, anything you want us to discuss, and we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
节目建议（这一集其实就是一个节目建议），请随时在Instagram上给我发私信：That Psychology Podcast，或者你也可以关注我的账号Jemis Beck。如果你对即将播出的节目、主题或任何你想让我们讨论的内容有任何想法，我们下周将带着另一集回归。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些磨难，你会作为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人从另一端走出来。收听“2%”。
That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
这就是IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“2%”。收听“Look Back At”播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图通过我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行和最喜欢的作家，来理解我们是如何熬过那段时期的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to and learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听“Look Back At It”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的“Learn the Hard Way”。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都极其不安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones.
多少男人穿着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就必须要这么做。请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听“Learn the Hard Way”。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次并在出售，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰基尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“困在爱中”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听“Love Trapped”播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。